while heavy rain is falling across
Southeast Texas and crews just started
releasing water from reservoirs
overwhelmed by the storm the decision is
aimed at protecting the city's downtown
but that controlled release will send
water streaming toward downtown and is
likely to worsen flooding in
neighborhoods already under water let's
return now to Norah O'Donnell reporting
live from Houston Norah good morning
yeah good morning to you as you're
talking about those reservoirs and that
extra release of water where's it going
to show up it's gonna show up in bayous
like this one behind me the Buffalo
Bayou which is now raising about half a
foot every hour in fact the gauges the
gauges they say are even broken here so
we can see it's even though the water
has risen even as we've been here just a
couple hours this morning the flooding
here in the Houston area it's expected
to last days they even say weeks some
areas in Southeast Texas could see up to
50 inches of rain before the threat from
Harvey is over now at least two deaths
are blamed on the storm we don't know
how many people are trapped in their
homes by this high water
the flooding catastrophe is being called
one of the worst disasters in Texas
history we should also note that Harvey
is moving slowly over the Gulf Coast the
National Weather Service says peak
flooding is expected Wednesday and
Thursday think about that it's going to
get worse than it is now
DeMarco Morgan is in Dickinson Texas
where he watched hundreds of people
rescued from a bridge overlooking a
flooded highway DeMarco good morning
Nora good morning to you just
heartbreaking we're about 30 miles east
from where you are and not too far from
the Dickason bayou but take a look
behind me the water is starting to
recede and it's doing so at a fast pace
but we are not in the clear just yet you
can now see the the markers they're
actually in the streets but you talked
about the rescues we saw nothing but
boat traffic yesterday in and out rescue
after rescue
from just above the highway you could
see the floodings devastating toll
people were driving trucks riding jet
skis and even paddling through the
rising water to rescue others those
without a ride waited along the
interstate in neck deep water early on
we saw two Coast Guard helicopters
swooped in to help those stranded one
desperate family member posted this
picture on social media showing several
elderly women trapped in a nursing home
as the morning continued we saw
firefighters lift what we believe to be
three of those women into the back of
this truck all 15 women at La Bella Vita
nursing home were saved
not all rescue efforts went smoothly a
small boat carrying two people and their
dog capsized as another one tried to
drag it to safety this family from
Lamarck rushed to Dickinson to rescue
their grandkids after the house was
overrun with water why was it important
to get here right away it was important
for me to get here right away because
this is my family this all I have and I
didn't want to happen to us like this in
his weather another family we spoke with
said they were trapped with nowhere to
go someone showed up to save them
I can think of four stranger
yeah the picture of the women at the
nursing home it just tugs at your heart
newer I'm not sure if you can see it but
there's a jet ski about two of them out
there they're still rescues are taking
place right now as we speak many of the
people who live in this area we saw a
couple earlier I'll walk it out because
the waters are starting to recede so
they're trying to get to a much drier
area we have also learned that most of
this location this neighborhood right
here is filled with low-income and
elderly residents many that we got a
chance to speak with who said they had
no place to go they were bused to a
nearby church we'll send things back to
you Wow DeMarco Morgan there and that's
why we're hearing FEMA talk about the
need to put 30,000 people in shelters I
know that our shot here it's hard to see
me it's because it's actually raining so
hard here in in downtown Houston there
are reports that there have been 11
trillion gallons of water have fallen on
the Houston area and that's what's
accounting for that we've also got
waters rising here on the Buffalo Bayou
we've been talking about this morning
because of that release of water from
the reservoir so we're actually going to
move locations right now and so Galle
we're gonna check back in with you as
soon as we can but for now I'm going to
send it back to you until we can get to
a different area all right Nora we look
forward to hearing from you be careful